- Can you teach me how to
make an animal balloon?
I want to do that!
- I definitely can.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay, all right.
(laughing)
(applause)
- So wait, there is,
okay wait, you want teal?
- Yes, I do want teal.
- I'm going to go red because I'm daring.
- Okay good!
Okay, so the important thing is that,
first of all when you blow it up
you always want to leave a little room,
because you got to fill out the room,
We're going to start at the
other end of the balloon.
- Oh, because when you blow
it up the air gets pushed!
- Exactly.
- Nice!
Displacement, okay.
(audience laughter)
- We're going to make just a
standard four legged animal,
which is a good base zone
because then you can always
elongate the neck, it's a giraffe,
shorten everything, it's a poodle!
- Yes!
(audience laughter)
So, we're going to start by making,
we're going to twist the
balloon into three circles.
So you're going to do one,
just twist it, don't be scared.
- I'm just afraid it's going
to pop, it's totally fine.
- Don't be scared.
- And then you're, oop, oh!
- You're going to hold on to it,
and then you're gonna do a second circle.
- How much do you have to
twist it for it to stay?
- Just like a few times.
And then you're going to
twist the third time around.
Kelly!
- I can't even get the--
- You have to twist and hold!
You have to twist and hold,
don't be afraid of the balloon.
- No, I'm not!
Like, I'm holding!
- Now hold...
- Hold.
- Now twist this section with this hand.
- Oh, oh you do, oh okay, okay.
- Good, good, good.
I've never taught this before,
it's like clown college.
- Okay, okay.
- And now fold it here
and twist that into that.
- Fold it, that into that.
- It seems scary.
- And these don't pop?
Are you serious?
- You can still do it,
you can still do it!
- I'm about to have a fight with you!
- You can still do it!
You can still do it, you can still do it!
- Okay wait, so then you take that-
- Into that, go, go, go, go!
You can do it, it's not going to pop.
It's not going to pop.
Don't fear the balloon!
Great, great, okay great!
So now you have to do that just--
- Yes!
(applause)
(laughter)
I did it!
- I feel like it's a head on a stick!
(applause drowns out Kelly)
- What do you do next?
- So then you do that a few more times.
So you make a little neck
and then you do, right, see and you twist
then twist again.
- Oh you do it again.
- And then you're going to fold again.
- You do it again.
- I'm going to move forward
but I'm going to double back--
- You go ahead because we're
going to be here for like
the length of a movie.
- and help, so then you
do that a few more times.
Yes, yes, yes, do it, do it, do it!
- Can you just do that?
- I just like to
encourage more than teach.
And then you do it again.
- Oh, oh, do it again.
- And next thing you know
you have a little dog.
- Wait, wait, so you do it again?
- (laughing) Do it again
and then one more time,
no wait--
- No, no, no.
- You have to do another leg.
- Another leg.
Were going to edit this,
it's going to be great!
- This is great, you're
going to do it one more time.
- It's going to be great!
- Holy 'word I can't say on Daytime'!
- Here, wait, you know what you can do?
Just fold it and twist it in, yes, yes.
- Yeah, like that?
And then what?
- No, no because you're
going to kill his body.
You have to twist this one into here.
- I don't want to kill his body.
Okay, okay and then you twist this?
- And that's the last one.
- Okay.
- Yes, yes, you're doing it!
- Okay, okay.
- Wait, well...
- What?
- Oh yeah!
That's great!
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughing)
- Yes!
(singing angelic tune)
- Yes, yes yes!
To everyone who said she couldn't do it!
- Suck it!
- She did it!